in a previous video we figured out how
to find the surface area of this cereal
box by figuring out the areas of each of
the six surfaces of the box and then
adding them all up i'm going to do that
again in this video but i'm going to do
it by visualizing a net for the box and
the way i think about a net of a box
like this is what would happen if you
were to if you were to if you were to
cut the cardboard and then flatten it
all out so what am i talking about well
what we have here we could imagine
making a cut in the box and the cut
could be
see i could make a cut back here
so i could make a cut
right over there i could cut it
i could cut it
right like this i could cut it
like that so if i just did that this top
flap would flap open so that would be
able to come out
like that and then i could also make a
cut
for this side
so i can make a cut back there
and i could make a cut
right over
here and now this side could flap
forward and i could do the same thing on
this other side right over here then
that could flap forward
and then the back side and i could i
could draw it so i would also have a cut
i'll draw it as a dotted line because
you're not really you're not supposed to
be able to see this cut
but the corresponding cut to this one on
this side that we can't see let me draw
a little bit neater than that the
corresponding cut would be right back
here
right back there and then a cut right
over here and so what would happen if we
were to flatten all of this out
well we would have
we would have the front of the box i'll
try to draw this as neatly as i can
so the front of the box
looks like this
we would have this top flap
which looks
like this
if we were to flatten it all out we have
these two side flaps so that's a side
flap
that's a side flap and this is another
this side flap right over here that's a
side flap
then we would have the bottom of the box
so the bottom of the box is going to
look like this
bottom of the box and then we have the
back of the box at the bottom is going
to be connected to we didn't we didn't
cut that so that we have the back of the
box
the back of the box
looks
like this and there we have it we've
made the net this is what would happen
if you made the cuts that i talked about
and then flattened the box out it would
look like this now how could we use this
net to find the surface area
well we just need to figure out the
surface area of this of this shape now
so how do we do that well we know a lot
about the dimensions we know that this
width right over here that this is 10
centimeters
10 centimeters from there
to there
we know
the height actually going all the way
from here all the way up because the
height of the box is 20 centimeters so
this is going to be
20 centimeters
right over here then you have another 20
centimeters you have another 20
centimeters right over here
and right over here if you like and then
you have see the depth of the box is
three centimeters so this is three
centimeters
three centimeters and then this is
three
centimeters
and so what is the area actually let me
just do one region first what is the
area of this entire region
that i am that i am shading in with this
blue color
well it's 10 centimeters
that is i'll do a color that you can see
a little bit more easily
it is
10 centimeters wide 10 centimeters
times what's the height 20
plus 3 plus 20 plus 3 so that's going to
be 40 plus 6 so times 46 centimeters
that's this blue area so that's going to
be 460
460 square centimeters
460 square centimeters and now we just
have to figure out the area of the two
flaps so this flap right over here
is 20 centimeters by three centimeters
so that's 60 centimeters squared
so 60
centimeters squared or 60 square
centimeters i should say and then this
flap is going to have the exact same
area another 60 square centimeters
60 square centimeters and you add
everything together we deserve a little
bit of a drumroll we get well this is
going to add up to 580
square centimeters which is the exact
thing we got in the other video where we
didn't use a net and you should just
it's nice to be able to do it either way
to be able to visualize the net or be
able to look at this and and think about
the different sides even the size that
you might not necessarily not
necessarily see